über dieses video möchte ich jetzt mit
uwe röhrig sprechen erst präsident der
polizeidirektion in göttingen herrlich
schönen guten abend sie haben das video
gerade gesehen was ist ihre meinung ist
dass noch satire
ja es ist nicht mein geschmack aber ich
würde es noch als native deuten ja
normal denkender mensch kann erkennen
dass das eben nicht die realität ist und
von daher muss man uns als satire werden
und so mache ich sagen es geht ja in dem
video um racial profiling wird das bei
der polizei denn angewendet und wenn ja
wann
ich gehe davon aus dass recht und
profiling bei der polizei nicht
angewandt wird es ist verboten
wir überprüfen das auch regelmäßig ich
kann nicht sagen dass es den einen oder
anderen fall nicht gibt deswegen hat
unser innenminister niedersachsen auch
eine studie in auftrag gegeben
beziehungsweise wirkte eine studie die
sich gerade mit dem thema racial
profiling beschäftigt bei uns ist es so
dass wir unseren kolleginnen kollegen
anhalten und genau darauf hinweisen dass
man etwas nicht geschehen soll wir
sprechen dass büros kräfte besprechung
an und versprechen dass in der
ausbildung an
der polizei gewalt an sich gerade ein
sehr brisantes thema was seine denn
dieses video ihrer meinung nach für eine
botschaft jetzt aus
dieses video soll die botschaft aus das
ist das thema racial profiling gerade in
den medien gibt das ist vielleicht auch
der bevölkerung diskutiert wird das wird
auch in der allgemeinheit diskutiert
aber es wird nicht diskutiert in der
polizei polizei ist im blickpunkt der
öffentlichkeit und wenn so ein thema
jetzt gerade auf die polizei zutrifft
dann ist natürlich auch so dass ich
satiriker comedian mit diesem thema
beschäftigen und die polizei mit den
blick rücken